professor we got a good one hot off the
press sir you're just talking about
Kanye West going off on Drake on his
Twitter just now I guess they're beefing
about um I mean how did it even start so
I mean it's it's the whole like you know
his son situation it's just like right
right continuation of that right but how
did this start
oh this rant started cuz Drake put in a
request to clear a sample for my old
song Oh Kanye and a is just pretty much
like way by the way what does that mean
clear sample means you can use it and
I'll take royalties or it means you can
use it royalty-free
nothing just means you can use it he'll
take royalty okay but it's just like you
can't you got to clear it yeah you gotta
go and if it doesn't clear you can't
post the degrees a song right okay yeah
so the main takeaway is that Kanye said
you over here sent him purple emojis and
I'm going through mental [ __ ] and
apparently on a radio show Kanye said
the Drake would send him quote the
purple emojis as a form of like
instigating so should the purple emoji
yeah which is just unfortunate that he
would say because there is not there are
there's not a the purple emoji although
there is well there is but I think the
one he means is like the Chief Keef
purple emoji you know like the devil
devil or purple hearts because this
doesn't Drake have a lyrics and a purple
heart
yeah but we the devil face right cuz
it's like he's [ __ ] with them yeah
but but toss us red like poor people
regular people that's a whole different
meaning bro we started laughing about
Drake sending Kanye eggplant emojis just
to [ __ ] with them you just hit whose do
you think about my dick yeah that would
piss me off
read this if you're gay yeah read this
every day honey what are you thinking
about you just read that text yeah ooh
it kinda just quick question quick
question what is what does this make you
think of
hey dude I know you said I couldn't you
can I can't clear the sample that's fine
can you clear my dick out of your mind
can you can you clear your thoughts of
my penis right now by the way I'm not
using the word penis I'm just using a
purple eggplant emoji it's like instead
of like the clapping hands emotion puts
it every other word of space
yo eggplant Kanye eggplant what are you
thinking about yeah hey what's good bro
eggplant I like my message now it's all
big and gay I know okay cool eggplant
[ __ ] Kanye's getting all mad stop
sending me that yeah purple emoji that's
like the rush it yeah well two things
I don't man my brains all over the place
I don't want to pivot to crazy want me
to come back to someone I want to say
about Russ okay but like god [ __ ]
dammit now I forgot the other a brain
can't handle two processes low IQ single
core processor oh no that's what it was
then Kanye tweets a picture of a Bible
verse okay and that is like first of all
Kanye is just a dad yeah that's all it
is that's that's why he says what he
says yeah this [ __ ] said to me
the purple emoji that doesn't have time
yeah it's a dad yeah he's got kids now
yeah he's trying to be still a musician
but in reality he probably only has
enough testosterone to like do the lawn
raise his kids and then go to sleep yeah
so you just having a hard time yeah so
he doesn't [ __ ] know didn't care
about him oh he definitely does his own
lawn for sure I mean no one kinda he
probably does he probably does yeah
probably I let anyone cut his lawn in a
weird fucked-up way no he cuts his own
lawn in a weird fucked-up way that's
what I mean yeah yeah yeah no instead of
letting a dude just like run it
yeah yeah he's like that's the way
people have been doing it forever but
that's not the right way goes out there
with poultry shears yeah got the grass
blade my blade cuts his grass blade by
Blake he's trying to give his Lana taper
just a very very like yeah very dull
face
and dude so we when I saw the Bible
first picture I'm laughing cuz I'm like
that is such like some religious dad
[ __ ] uh uh that's like like I'm always
dead whenever he would like get pissed
at him he would like go read his Bible
yeah to try to not whip his ass okay
like it's like an anger management tool
yeah yeah like he's like searching you
know that's a man looking for resolved
that's like such some dad [ __ ] oh yeah
you like Lord help me not to beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of this kid show me
something
like that is so funny yeah and I just
let me find the courage to not to not
beat this kid yes help me dear God God I
just need a little help your God in
heaven
I mean I swear to gosh I'm gonna [ __ ]
him up worse than he [ __ ] up the
drywall
okay don't know where he learned that
from but I'm gonna [ __ ] him up please
yeah I was I was imagining Drake like
looking at that Bible verse and like
taking like a hard swallow and then
putting cardboard in his ass cheeks butt
in his pants I mean I guess you know you
know siblings get their ass whooped
I always evaded the ass-whooping okay
like you know when you you know when you
get the discipline you figure out weird
ways as a kid to try to like compensate
for the damage if a cardboard is like a
protection yeah I had a few friends and
siblings do that [ __ ] yeah I just like
get like a box with like some piece of
cardboard like try stuff it in your
jeans and the parents fall for that [ __ ]
hell no that's the funniest part but I
just imagine Drake is a grown man like
ripping apart like an adidas they go to
Spanglish
yeah [ __ ] is that what he's got armor
yeah he's got armor okay
back of the kitchen gets a [ __ ] frying
pan a meat tenderizer I hear we gotta
prank
maybe that Drake tearing apart India's
box and stuffing it in his [ __ ] oh yo
sweats yeah I got an armored up dude nah
dad's coming home I'll beat my ass
Drake such a teenager dude he's such a
[ __ ] 35 year old teenager how old is
he at 30 to 30 is he 32 yeah he's 30 to
30 T's actually 16 yeah yeah that's what
he is
any sending emojis to a grown-ass man
grown as man yeah the eggplant no laughs
yeah four-year-old is a book
Kanye pulls out his he's got like the
hip Klip first phone like you stylish
everywhere else but he's like all these
dad tendencies are leaking through he's
got the hip Klip or his iphone clip on
it it's like the leather holster yeah
he's got a blackberry it's got the extra
battery to it but text size is way too
big with the foot can only see half a
text screen with the [ __ ] like
plastic cover but it's like a bunch of
lint in there no it's like the it's like
the stick on one but it's like half
[ __ ] up yeah one side just one piece
of Kim's hair in there it's an otterbox
yes easy color daughter bak magnetic
OtterBox he pulls out a stylus to open
the text this [ __ ] trick beat
this [ __ ] ass so bad stylus
[Music]
hold and have his bags I'm trying to
flex not trying to flex take your fish
to nurse and break that's not a flex